[Music]  faithful to her as long as you both  shall live  I will  the mystery behind those giggles during  Prince Harry and Megan Marcos vows is  finally answered  in a new interview with toning country  Meghan's longtime friend actress Janina  gavankar explains that the laughter had  to do with the crowd outside st.  George's Chapel quote when the vows were  happening they would cheer and we could  hear them it was so heartwarming really  it filled our hearts the 37 year old  star also commented on how intimate the  Royal Wedding felt  despite the 600 guests in attendance  telling the mad quote if you were in the  chapel it felt like a small wedding  because we didn't see Meghan's massive  walk up the church aisle - preceded the  choir  [Music]  Janina adds quote it felt like we were  just right there with her with both of  them  [Applause]